in der nächsten woche am nächsten
samstag ist sozusagen unser kleiner
unser mini freedom day ist es so ich
hoffe nicht das würde ja bedeuten dass
die maßnahmen dann alle auslaufen bis
auf in den in den einrichtungen für
besonders gefährdete gruppen also
meinetwegen pflegeeinrichtungen kranken
also ich glaube dass wir bei der
incidents die wir derzeit haben die
hotspot regelungen die ich mit
justizminister buschmann gemacht habe
dass also die länder die nutzen werden
wie jetzt in mecklenburg vorpommern also
geplant auch in hamburg ich hoffe dass
also auch andere länder nachziehen und
hierzu also regeln kommen die gerade in
den städten und lanthan wo wir sehr hohe
inzidenz haben nur noch hohe
sterblichkeit haben die die regeln so
nutzen dass dort mehr schutz möglich ist
als wenn man auf die regierung
verzichtet und einfach also so tut als
wenn die pandemie vorbei gesetz besagt
ja erstmals läuft alles aus das ist
richtig aber es läuft nicht aus wenn die
landtage beschließen neue regeln sich zu
geben enorm das gesetz mitgemacht das
besagt es läuft alles aus genau wo außer
in den hotspots
jetzt werben sie dafür dass es ganz
große hotspots gibt das ganze länder
sich zu hotspots erklären heißt auf oder
seine leute sagen sie ich bin dafür ich
unterschreibe das gesetz ich betreibe
dieses gesetz um es tatsächlich gesetz
werden zu lassen das alles auch ausläuft
ich möchte auf der einen seite das alles
ausläuft und auf der anderen seite
möchte ich das fast ganz deutschland
doch dann eben wieder keine auslaufende
maßnahmen haben ja das ist ja kein
widerspruch sein das hat ja einfach eine
recht nein überhaupt nicht das ist kein
widerspruch dass hatte einfach eine
rechtliche komponente der rechtliche
hintergrund ist der der justizminister
in qua amt hat auf der grundlage also
der bewertung der situation gesagt eine
deutschlandweite gefährdung der
gesundheitsversorgung ist nicht mehr
gegeben
daher sind deutschlandweit
einschränkungen rechtlich nicht mehr
machbar wenn sie mir dann nennen sie mir
eine region oder ein großes bundesland
bei dem sie im moment sagen würden da
bin ich froh dass alle maßnahmen
auslaufen
das ist doch ob ich vor bin ich habe
doch gesagt rechtlich geht es gar nicht
anders also sage ich ich mal ganz im
ernst dass jeder kapiert rechtlich wäre
es nicht möglich gewesen egal wer
verhandelt hätte
deutschlandweite regeln auf rechts
warten weil es eine deutschlandweite
gefährdung nicht mehr geld aber es wirkt
inkonsistent und es wirkt unehrlich sie
unterschreiben erst in der ampel region
das gesetz mit das sagt aller maßnahmen
laufen aus und dann anschließend kommen
sie daher und sagen ich wünsche mir
eigentlich dass ganz deutschland ein
hotspot ist das habe ich ja nie gesagt
ist es das ist eine unterstellung und
zum zweiten hier geht es nicht um
münchen sondern hier geht es ja um also
was ist möglich es war auf der grundlage
der rechtlichen analyse von
justizminister nicht möglich
bundeseinheitliche regeln zum beispiel
masken pflicht in ganz deutschland zu
beschließen es war einfach rechtlich
möglich ob ich das jetzt wünsche oder
nicht oder ob buschmann das wird ja
sagen wir buschmann hätte gesagt ich
will jetzt die masten sich in ganz
deutschland hätte es auch nicht machen
können denn auf der druck ganz gut sind
vergänglich den faden kommen ich mir das
selbst buschmann wer nicht in der lage
gewesen wäre dass justizminister
busemann wer nicht in der lage gewesen
jetzt zu sagen masken sich in ganz
deutschland war auf der grundlage seiner
eigenen juristischen analyse sind solche
einschränkungen nur noch möglich
deutschlandweit nicht in hotspots wenn
es eine deutschlandweite gefährdung gibt
aber sie haben ja gerade gesagt dass
seine unterstellung dass sie jetzt nicht
wollten dass ganz deutschland ein
hotspot wäre das heißt wo ist aus ihrer
sicht im moment möglich dass alle
maßnahmen fallen also dass tatsächlich
das passiert was in ihrem gesetz steht
mein wunsch ist natürlich mein wunsch
ist und war natürlich dass zum beispiel
die masken pflicht in ganz deutschland
gilt das ist ja klar und das war auch
mein wunsch während der verhandlungen
also auch jetzt würde ich wenn das
rechtlich ging die masken pflicht für
ganz norddeutschland wollen natürlich
und kein epidemiologe wird es anders
wollen und auch im expertenrat werden
wahrscheinlich alle der meinung dass die
masken pflicht in ganz deutschland jetzt
sinnvoll wäre aber das ist doch gar
nicht die frage sondern die frage ist ob
es doch noch eine rechtliche grundlage
gibt und da war die antwort des
justizministers ist nicht mehr da wo
kann aus ihrer sicht im moment auf die
hotspot regelung in deutschland
verzichtet werden verzichtet werden kann
überall dort wo die gesundheitliche
versorgung muss verzichtet werden dort
wo die gesundheitliche versorgung nicht
gefährdet ist aber sie können keine
region nennen sie sagen jetzt sein weil
sie vielen ja auch die region nennen das
haben sie auch öffentlich getan wo sie
wollen dass die hotspot regelung im
moment greift ja aber man merkt
kompromiss ich werde am montag außer die
gesundheitsminister der länder also
quasi in
einer gesundheitsministerkonferenz
darüber informieren was aus meiner sicht
die kriterien sind nach denen also
bundesländer die hotspots bestimmen
können und die kriterien sind eigentlich
ganz einfach zu nennen ist in einer
region oder in einer stadt oder
vielleicht am ganzen bundesland die also
im
versorgung im krankenhaus so gefährdet
das zum beispiel planbare eingriffe im
moment nicht gemacht werden weil zu viel
personal ausgefallen ist oder zu viele
kurven patienten im krankenhaus in das
ist das erste das zweite ist die
notfallversorgung durch diese
krankenhaus er kann nicht mehr
dargestellt werden das dritte ist also
wenn in der pflege werden unter grenzen
die wir quantitativ festhalten die
werden unterschritten und das vierte ist
die krankenhäuser müssen patienten die
schon da sind in andere krankenhäuser
verlegen was sie nicht mehr versorgen
können mit diesen vier kriterien wären
die länder in der lage die hotspot
regelungen umzusetzen darüber werden wir
sprechen und ich appelliere einfach an
die länder jetzt ich weiß dass das
gesetz kompliziert ist ich weiß dass das
nicht schön ist wenn die landtage das
beschließen müssen aber es ging ja nicht
an also ich bin appelliere an die länder
ist jetzt zu machen trotzdem ist zu
nutzen die länder werden mit dem
gleichen problem konfrontiert also jetzt
zum beispiel schlägt
gesundheitspolitik aus bayern da steckt
vor lasst uns doch die masken pflicht in
ganz deutschland genau wissen forscher
und dann ist es eben so dass unsere
ministerpräsidentin total ag ja aber ist
ja egal also ob er das vorschlägt oder
nicht also es ist vollkommen unerheblich
es geht rechtlich nicht das ist ja das
problem ist dass das ja wie ein trick
von lauterbach bei den ankommen da sei
es doch ihre ladung stellt sich hin in
berlin und sagt mit den grünen und mit
der fdp dann fallen am nächsten samstag
alle maßnahmen und derselbe minister
derselbe gesundheitsminister setzt sich
anschließend hin und sagt ich werbe aber
dafür zumindest in etlichen
bundesländern dass dieselben maßnahmen
eben nicht fallen das kommt bei den
menschen wie ein trick ja gut also dass
kommt also als erstes also ich habe
einiges also
hier vorzutragen aber ich habe keine
tricks nötig das ist nicht meine art das
ist also die unterstellungen die saat
ich lese dass manchmal höre dass und so
weiter sondern damit beschäftigt nicht
mal wie es ankommt weil die frage ist
doch wenn ihnen jemand sagt herr
lauterbach ich streiche dass das gilt ab
samstag nicht mehr und dann kommt ihr
ministerkollege und sagt das geht doch
noch es hat nur jetzt jemand anders
beschlossen ist es natürlich für den
betroffenen bürger am ende wurde es
bleibt beim selben recht es bleibt bei
denselben maßnahmen ist hat nur jemand
anders beschlossen nee das ist nicht der
unterschied wäre es beschlossen hat und
dann der unterschied ist die
rechtsgrundlage
anders ausgedrückt erstmalig habe dafür
gesorgt dass wir bis zum zweiten vierten
überhaupt einen übergang haben sonst
hätte es schon den freedom day sofort
gegeben es wäre ja fast gar nicht mehr
zu einer einigung gekommen wir haben ja
bis zur letzten stunde verhandelt ja so
dass es überhaupt noch einen übergang
gab wenn die tatsache dass wir es
überhaupt einen übergang haben bei
dieser riesigen fallzahl ist ja muss man
ja ganz offen es ist ja buschmann und
mir zu verdanken die praxis einsatz und
zum zweiten ich muss immer nur sagen
wenn die rechtsgrundlage für
einschränkungen in deutschland weiter
nicht mehr gilt kann sie nur noch lokal
gelten und werden sie lokal aber also
somit haben wir jetzt die situation
bundesweit geht es nicht mehr lokal
gegner ist und viele der länder
schmollen und mache noch wahlkampf sie
sagen der bund hat uns im stich gelassen
hat nur lokal klingt ja als wäre jetzt
ein teil von berlin oder wie der
westteil von paderborn betroffen aber
die wahrheit ist ja dann das ganz
mecklenburg vorpommern könne heisst oder
ganz banal dazu eine frage die es
nochmal runterbrechen dieses problem ja
einerseits fällt die massen nicht in den
supermärkten auf der anderen seite haben
sie sofort gesagt sie werben dafür dass
die supermärkte das durch ihr hausrecht
einfach umsetzen unserer zuschauer
harald bands aus heimsheim fragt er
lauterbach warum schieben sie ihre
verantwortung und damit den schwarzen
peter jetzt den supermärkten zu die mit
ihrem haus rechten masken pflicht
durchsetzen sollen den gesetzes pflicht
sich mit der regierungskoalition nicht
festlegen konnten also sie kriegen das
nicht geregelt und jetzt schieben sie
den schwarzen peter so sagt er dass den
supermärkten rewe zum beispiel sie ja
aber du bist doch immer die gleiche
antwort die rechtliche grundlage für
mich das zu machen ist nicht da sonst
hätte ich das gemacht ich hätte so zu
sagen wenn die rechtliche grundlage da
gewesen wäre hätten wir die massen
pflicht nicht verloren sie wäre ja sagen
ganz deutschland die richtig aber ich
hatte keine rechtliche grundlage
die masken pflicht in ganz deutschland
durchzusetzen weil die gesundheitliche
gefährdung in ganz deutschland dafür
nicht mehr da ist wenn jetzt ein
supermarkt auch auf meine empfehlung vom
hausrecht gebrauch macht dann ist die
rechtliche grundlage dafür da bei einer
sache für die es keine rechtliche
grundlage mehr gibt weil die
gesundheitliche gefährdung nicht mehr
ausreichend gegeben ja bei dieser frage
hat rewe mehr macht als der
bundesgesundheitsminister war das so
genannte hausrecht nutzen kann und der
gesundheitsminister eine solche masken
pflicht nur beschliessen könnte wenn es
ganz deutschland so ginge dass wir eine
gefährdung der gesundheitlichen
versorgung gefährden befürchten müssen
könnte es sein dass wenn die frage nicht
so wichtig ist dass sie's regel dürfen
sondern nur rewes regeln darf dass die
frage dann vielleicht gar nicht so
wichtig ist und man einfach die maske im
supermarkt nicht mehr tragen müssen also
ich kann es ja nur empfehlen ich hätte
auf jeden fall wenn die rechtliche
grundlage dafür da gewesen wäre die
masken pflicht war das ein verfahren ist
wo ich mit geringem aufwand viel
erreichen hätte ich das fortgeführt und
jetzt kann ich einfach nur appellieren
an die länder in den hotspots das zu
machen und ich freue mich auch wenn das
also supermärkte machen das ist gar
keine frage reagiert eigentlich haben
wir haben edeka rewe penny aldi lidl und
so weiter haben die alle gesagt hat es
ja wohl in der bundespressekonferenz
gesagt ja wie also ich werde am montag
die reaktionen bekommen und kann ihnen
dann gerne berichten ich kann es zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht aber
tatsächlich ist das eine grundlage ist
wie gesagt ich mir ist wichtig in der
heutigen zeit wird ja oft gearbeitet mit
narrativen es werden geschichten erzählt
dass und das ist da gelungen da hat sich
der durchgesetzt und so weiter so von
der politik heißt mehr lernen als sieger
jahr also genau
märchenstunden und so weiter und so fort
wichtig ist dass man bei diesen dingen
auch die fakten beachtet und fakt war
hier die grundlage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in seiner
reform war die dass wir nicht mehr das
bund für die nicht wollen haben gruppen
einschränkungen beschließen konnten das
ist im wesentlichen auch übrigens eine
rechtslage gegen die ungeimpften ich
habe diese rechtslage nicht geschaffen
und ich habe ihm schon gesagt wenn es
eine andere gelbe weg sogar vor gewesen
aber die grundlage ist die wir machen
nicht mehr viel um die ungeimpften zu
schützen noch einmal zu rewe zu aldi
penny sollen die das nur den hotspot
hotspots durchsetzen ihr hausrecht die
masken pflicht umzusetzen oder soll das
in ganz deutschland das habe ich doch
gerade schon gesagt ich hätte mich
gefreut und hielte es für sinnvoll wenn
wir eine masken pflichtigen ganz neues
in deutschland genannt
ich habe ja also wird nur dass wir das
muss ja gut ich muss das noch mal
wiederholen so dass du das zuschauer gut
kapieren und erwartungsvoll wenn die
rechtliche grundlage dafür da gewesen
wäre das hätte hätten wir eine masken
pflicht für ganz deutschland bald nur
dass die dass jeder versteht also aus
epidemiologischer sicht wäre die masken
für ganz deutschland sinnvoll gewesen
sie ging aber nicht weil die rechtliche
grundlage ich frage nur deswegen nach
weil das ja kompliziert werden können
hat in einem landstrich in dem man kaum
noch infekt aalen hat das machen werden
sehen der marktleiter von penny daher
gehen muss und muss sagen sie mir das ja
einen neukölln oder kreuzberg
wer das ist komplizierter ist auch nicht
wünschenswert
haben sie aktuellen überblick wo
eigentlich am nächsten samstag die
freiheiten die korona maßnahmen komplett
fallen das kann niemand haben wir die
beschlüsse fahren ja in dieser s
kommenden woche und können sie es im
moment über den daumen pein betrifft das
die hälfte deutschland die länder wird
die länder also haben sich noch nicht
deklariert ich hoffe dass die länder
also in viele länder warten ab was
passiert ist in den nächsten tag was
machen andere länder viele länder
beobachten sich viele länder im
wahlkampf ist diese auch sehr viel
parteipolitik damit noch mal dass ich
schade ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
doch mein appell an die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen sein
dass wir hingehen und sagen schaut auf
diese vier kriterien überlastung der
krankenhaus dort wo das der fall ist
sagen wir dass ein tor zu machen das
einheitlich möglichst einheitlich land
gehen wir gut voran